in Peninsula apartment Hong Kong a
veteran Sergeant named Tai falls from a
high floor and sustains serious injuries
he desperately tries getting up but ends
up breaking one of his legs after some
time the police arrive on the scene and
find Ty covered in blood they also
discover Lang a senior inspector
unconscious on the seventh floor's
Corridor several police officers are
then dispatched to find the perpetrator
but all in vain later in the hospital
the police officers of teams A and B
argue with each other as the leader of
Team B George accuses inspector Ling of
being responsible for Ty's brutal
condition after a while Ling regains
Consciousness and finds himself in the
hospital with his wife Hazel and their
adopted son sunny as the family is
having an emotional moment Ling's
co-worker ghost interrupts them and asks
Lang about the murder however the latter
seems to have lost his recent memories
because of the serious impact on his
head that night Ling and ghost pay a
visit to Tai who is lying unconscious in
the ICU has watches in disbelief ghost
helps him recall the incidents from the
previous days he mentions that the
entire police department has been
separated into several groups to solve
the recent murder cases but so far there
has been no breakthrough the
blood-letting serial killer has already
killed two innocent citizens in the past
month but still his motive is unknown
his killing techniques are equally
gruesome the killer drills holes into
his victims bodies drains their blood
and leaves them to die furthermore ghost
reveals that Ty and Ling were seen
entering the peninsula apartment at 3 pm
the day before according to the CCTV
footage Tai was 15 minutes earlier than
Lang however the police are unable to
determine why the two went to Peninsula
apartment without any backup the next
day Ling heads to his workplace the
police headquarters and informs his boss
that he will continue to handle the
murder case the boss suggests that he
rest and let George's team handle the
case but Ling is adamant on finding the
killer later ghost approaches laying in
his cabin and starts discussing the case
he reveals that the first victim was a
sports Professor named Ken Chiang who is
a decent man with no criminal record the
second victim was a 40 year old comic
artist named Juno ma who had no wife
money or enemies according to ghost the
connection between the victims is the
way that they died as both were bloodlet
using an electric drill additionally
both murders occurred near Jagged Island
the same place where Ling lives the next
day Ling and ghost visit Peninsula
apartment and start looking for some
Clues suddenly Ling starts getting
fragments of his Memories Back and
recalls that he was on the ninth floor
not the seventh when he saw Tai lying on
the ground in the next scene the two
begin investigating the ninth floor and
soon discover a suspicious room inside
they find a deceased monkey that was
also bloodlet they also find the
drilling machine used by the murderer
Upon returning back to the police
quarters Ling overhears his boss telling
ghost to drop the case and focus solely
on laying indicating that the department
is suspicious about him after work Ling
returns home and while he is chilling on
the porch he notices that Sonny's toy is
damaged with several holes in it
startled Ling asks his son about who
damaged his toy and the little boy
replies you did hearing this he
immediately heads to the storeroom and
looks for his drill but surprisingly it
is missing just then he notices two
drilled holes in the wall and a bloody
print from his own hand the strange
occurrence is further confused Lange and
though he tries his best to recall the
past days he fails for the time being he
just hides the marks with paint however
the very next morning he notices another
bloody handprint next to the previous
one leaving him terrified he then
confronts his family and warns them not
to leave the house Hazel asks for the
reason but Lynn gives her none later he
goes to a doctor to find out when he
will regain his memory as he is in great
stress he mentions that he is an honest
person but no one believes him anymore
when the doctor asks what worries him
Ling replies family he reveals that two
years ago his son drowned in a pond
because of his negligence and since then
he hasn't been able to shake off that
guilt now all he cares about is the
safety of his family but with a murderer
on the loose it's hard not to worry
hearing this the doctor suggests that he
undergo another blood test as well as a
brain scan in the evening Ling visits
the morgue where ghost informs him that
the drilled holes on the victim's backs
are not random they appear to have some
pattern and are identical on both the
bodies elsewhere we see a female victim
who has been kept inside a filthy
looking room just like the other victims
she has been drilled on her back and
both of her eyes are nailed somehow she
manages to crawl out of the abandoned
room but as soon as she reaches the road
she is crushed by an oncoming truck a
few moments later Lange along with the
police force arrives at the scene and
seals off the entire area surprisingly
even this time the murder has taken
place near Jagged Island following this
Ling returns home to find his sister
Minnie who is just returned from the
United States he is happy to see his
sister but forbids her too from going
out of the house the same night Ling is
thinking about the murder case when he
notices his biological Sons drawing of a
rabbit with several dots on it he
quickly Compares it with that of the
victim's whole pattern and lo and behold
it matches the next day a stressling
visits the doctor and gets to know that
his brain is normal but his blood
contains a high concentration of the
drug Propranolol the doctor further
explains that while Propranolol treats
high blood pressure it also causes
dizziness and short-term memory loss in
fact he hasn't been able to regain his
memory because of the continuous intake
of the drug this shock sling as he
doesn't recall taking any drugs later
Ling and ghost go to the abandoned room
from before in hopes of finding a clue
in the middle of the search Lang spots a
filthy looking man outside and begins
chasing him down the woods however ghost
who sees No One Believes that his friend
has gone insane shortly after the two
head over to Ling's place while they are
having a drink Minnie walks in with
their childhood photos Ling and ghost go
through the photos when suddenly Lane
comes across a picture of himself with
four other kids Behind the picture there
is mention about the first two victims
taken aback he checks the picture again
and realizes that two of the kids are
the victims after a while ghost has a
private conversation with hazel and
expresses his concerns about Lang just
then Sonny walks in with several
drawings one of which contains the same
rabbit drawing from before as soon as
ghost sees it he puts it in his pocket
later while dining he shows the drawing
to Lang and inquires about it but the
latter is just as speechless as a result
a disappointed ghost storms out of the
place the following day at Police
Headquarters one of the officers
approaches ghost and shows him some
photos recovered from the female
victim's Place upon looking at them he
notices the same picture he saw in
Ling's house just then he receives
urgent news and heads to the morgue it
turns out that Tai passed away last
night and when with this their best
chance of finding the murderer is also
gone following this ghost drives the
link to Jagged Island and demands to
learn the truth Ling believes that
someone is framing him and that he is
Innocent but ghost doesn't buy it
instead he reminds laying of the rabbit
drawing and also shows him the same
photo revealing that the victims were
actually Ling's childhood neighbors
because of the damning evidence ghost
mentions that he can't trust his friend
anymore he then starts arguing with Lang
and accidentally gets knocked over the
ledge resulting in a deadly fall
realizing what he has done Ling rushes
to help his friend but even now ghost
tries calling the authorities this
leaves Ling with no choice so he
reluctantly kills his friend later at
home he receives a phone call from the
police who inquire about his whereabouts
at the time of ghost's death link
pretends to be unaware of the incident
and lies that he was at home however the
police department believes he is unfit
for Duty and makes him take a long leave
despite this he remains committed to his
and decides to apprehend the murderer
one way or another one day as Ling is
spending some alone time near a pond he
notices the same man spying on him
realizing that he is the murderer Ling
immediately goes after him and an
intense Chase ensues after a while the
murderer enters Sunny school and
apprehends him but as soon as Ling
arrives he runs away after the incident
Ling returns home and closes all the
doors while keeping an eye out the
window Minnie asks about the matter but
Ling decides to explain everything after
it's over a while later he walks
upstairs and discovers the same photo
stuck on the closet he examines it
closely and realizes that he had bullied
one of the boys severely in the past he
used to call him beggar boy and even
called his mother dirty just then Ling
notices Sonny smiling at him from the
balcony surprisingly the little kid
starts talking in a grown-up voice taken
aback Ling asks if he is a ghost but
Sunny reveals that he is none other than
the bagger boy it turns out that he is
disease called anti-aging sickness which
caused his body to stop growing after a
certain age while keeping his
intelligence normal Sunny further
reveals that he knows everyone from
Ling's family because they share a
common father following this he starts
narrating about the past when his mother
brought him from Southeast Asia to find
his father but when they arrived at the
father's house they learned that he had
remarried a wealthy woman and had two
children despite this sunny and his mom
tried convincing the father to let them
stay but he refused forcing them to live
on the streets from that day onwards
their lives began to deteriorate by the
day they got a shady house to live in
but his mother had to sell herself every
day to meet the household necessities
then one day she passed away due to a
venereal disease and then it was just
sunny all by himself this is when he
decided to use his tiny frame to his
Advantage at first he was adopted by a
kind family but he could only stay for a
short time or else they would discover
his sickness in order to survive he then
began selling their babies to a child
trafficker eventually with time he
grasped the mechanism of evil doings
hearing all this a confused Ling
inquires as to why he is doing this and
little Sonny replies that he simply
wants Ling to experience the feeling of
being wronged he then reveals that he
isn't doing this alone but rather he has
a partner the murderer is the same
person Ling chased after earlier his
name is mang and he has early aging
sickness because of this he ages quickly
but has extremely good intelligence and
Agility then Sonny starts explaining
about the incident at Peninsula
apartment he deliberately faddling with
a lot of poisoned cakes causing him to
lose his memory he then called Tai into
the apartment pretending to just be lost
soon after he texted Lange claiming that
his pistol is on the ninth floor when
Tai reached it first mang attacked him
drilled his body and threw him from the
seventh floor of the apartment he then
knocked Lang unconscious and dragged him
to the same floor Lin questions why he
wasn't killed and sunny replies that he
wants to imprison him them because some
punishments are worse than death he also
reveals that he killed the three victims
just so he could frame him enraged Ling
attempts to kill sunny but as he is
about to do so his wife and many
intervene he desperately tries to
explain about the little man's reality
but as expected No One Believes him
later that evening George arrives at
Ling's house and transports him to the
police station for investigation George
questions him about the murders but Ling
remains silent hence due to the lack of
evidence he is released on bail one day
Ling drags Sonny to a floating platform
in the middle of the sea to scare him
however it turns out that it was Sonny's
plan all along to get Ling out of the
house so that man could murder his
family hearing this Ling rushes back
home but it's too late mang has already
executed Hazel the sight of his wife's
horrific death breaks Ling from the
inside and he starts crying
uncontrollably but soon he gets up and
rushes outside for vengeance when Ling
steps out of the house Sunny locks the
door from inside just then mang arrives
with his drilling machine and the two
start fighting while they're at it sunny
makes his way out meanwhile Ling manages
to overpower mang and brutally drills
him to death after killing one
perpetrator he heads out to kill sunny
and eventually Corners him on a cliff
but before he can strike the cops show
up with his sister Lang tries explaining
that the child is a monster but no one
listens to him now with no options left
he proceeds to kill sunny but one of the
cops shoots him down in the last scene
we are shown that Ling has been
incarcerated in a prison he has been
found guilty of six murders two of whom
were his own friends the movie ends as
Sunny sits near the sea delighted that
he successfully completed his mission
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching